they don't exist anymore and it's
too bad they don't exist anymore i'm a
registered independent a lot of the
moderate liberals have gone into the
independent precincts
um now
but if you are not a doctrinaire
progressive leftist
you get smeared by your own people
i mean they'll attack you they'll turn
on you you've got to get it's got got to
be doctrinaire down the line look what's
happening to bill maher
now bill maher is a very liberal person
extremely so
but he then is fed up with woke
and he look he knows what's absurd
because he's a comedian and that's how
he makes his living he knows biden's
absurd
he knows the whole administration is a
catastrophe
well he says that they turn on him fast
so i want to talk to you a little bit
about media you know obviously you have
a an extensive sort of remarkable uh
pedigree in mainstream media in uh what
was once mainstream i don't know that
it's mainstream anymore let's say
corporate press and you're doing you're
doing the online thing now which
obviously is the future of all this is
there anything you miss from the daily
cable news grind that you feel like you
got there that you can't get doing what
we're doing now
well i was at fox news for more than 20
years as 16 as the highest rated cable
show in the country by far by the way it
wasn't even close
and i had pretty much done all i could
do
uh
for the corporation
and then before that i worked with abc
news as a correspondent cbs's is a
correspondent syndicated program called
inside edition so i've basically seen it
and done it all in my career
and uh when i left the daily grind
believe me it was
because i write everything i say i have
no writers i never have had any writers
and i design the programs i don't have
producers design them for me i'm like
jerry lewis i do you know i sweep up
after everybody leaves i get everybody
coaxed do you even a phone i mean do you
have someone that's doing some fact
checking when you're writing your
monologue
checkers and bookers yeah i can't do
that right um but i all the stuff that
you see on screen comes from me and i
was tired
um and it was a big change in management
as everybody knows at fox and it was a
different crew
and i said you know uh
they were gunning for me uh
the far left cadres
um and i didn't think i was going to get
protection and and it just it wasn't
worth it anymore didn't need the money
and then when i got out of there i said
look
the future of uh media
isn't in the corporations they're all
going to go down and they are every one
of them is declining and dramatically
but the future is to develop a news
agency that's independent from all of
that
and present it to the folks and see if
they'll pay for it
and they are
i mean i am making
a lot of money on bill o'reilly.com i'm
not in it for the money i don't do it
for that
but there are
hundreds of thousands of people willing
to pay
for honesty and that's what i provide
you may not agree with me
but i'm going to back up what i say so i
thought it would work it is working we
are the most successful news agency in
the world now we're a worldwide
operation
and we combine television with radio and
we got more than 300
radio stations across the country so
it's all going my way it's an enormous
amount of work that's for sure but i'm
glad i don't answer to anybody there's
no dopey meetings i don't have to play
on i never played office politics i
don't have to even be subjected to that
anymore so it's a relief are there any
lefty counterparts doing something
similar to uh what you've done what i'm
doing say you know there's this sort of
broad
new sort of right-leaning conservative
thing happening online that seems really
robust all sorts of different people who
are more traditional conservatives
libertarians ex-libs there's a whole
group of people doing this really
successfully is there anyone that you
see kind of from the other side that's
doing it successfully that you respect
that you try to engage with i'm having a
hard time finding any of these people
willing to talk
yeah i don't i don't live in that world
um i get clip service and i know what
people are saying
um but i don't live in that world but
there isn't anyone
on a a regular
platform on the net
that is looking at it from a moderate
liberal point of view
no one is that is that
is that sad for you i mean you're a long
islander like you grew up i i know i
know where you grew up in long island
i'm a long islander i grew up around a
lot a lot a lot of people who were sort
of moderate liberals and they seemingly
just don't exist anymore
they don't exist anymore and it's
too bad they don't exist anymore i'm a
registered independent a lot of the
moderate liberals have gone into the
independent
precincts um now
but if you are not a doctrinaire
progressive leftist
you get smeared by your own people
i mean they'll attack you they'll turn
on you you gotta it's got got to be
doctrinaire down the line look what's
happening to bill maher
now bill maher is a very liberal person
extremely so
but he then is fed up with woke
and he look he knows what's absurd
because he's a comedian and that's how
he makes his living he knows biden's
absurd he knows the whole administration
is a catastrophe
well he says that they turn on him fast
do you think he'll help him you think
he'll ever fully turn and do the
scariest of all things i don't think so
because he lives in hollywood you live
in hollywood his his cocktail party
invites have been down by about 50 i
understand if he goes into traditional
precincts he'll never get invited
anywhere and that's what these people
live for that's what they live for the
social aspect of it that kind of thing
they accept it in the bubble manhattan
dc
la
it's boring to me i never wanted to be
in the bubble
um that never affected me at all
i mean i had i produced exact produce uh
four movies
and we were nominated for three emmys
and i was shocked
the movies are really good based on the
killing books
but i was stunned we didn't win because
you're not going to give o'reilly
an entertainment emmy i want three news
emmys but
um that's a bubble out there in
entertainment that's part of the reason
we're in such a mess
because entertainment industry and the
media news media they're aligned with
the progressive left
and that makes the progressive laugh far
more powerful than they would be because
they don't have that greater number of
people but the silver lining of course
is that people do seem to be tuning out
and tuning in to some of them they are
tuning out no doubt about it so since
you are in new york and you are a true
new yorker uh i often show clips on my
show of kathy hoechel a woman who nobody
voted for who seems to be
probably the second most authoritarian
governor we have in the country maybe to
gavin newsom but she might be number one
you could probably throw whitmer in
there too what is going on in new york
where where is that spirit of new york
to fight back it's the same thing
that we see in california in illinois uh
one party
in new york democrats outnumber
republicans two to one on the voter
rolls
uh kathy hokel is uh
a person who will never solve any
significant problem
she's simply not smart enough it's not
like biden biden's a whole different
thing hulk was just not smart enough
and doesn't particularly care she
doesn't live in new york city she
doesn't care if the city is crime ridden
quality of life is collapsed subways are
dangerous
doesn't care doesn't care that six seven
hundred thousand affluent new yorkers
have left the state uh doesn't care
again power that's what she wants she's
in the machine no bail law she could
knock that out doesn't care she could
fire bragg the uh
prosecutor in manhattan who won't
prosecute any even violent crimes she
could fire won't do it
so
my message to new york voters is this
what you want
apparently it is
apparently it is dave
i don't think long island where i am is
like that anymore long island has
changed
all right but manhattan certainly
doesn't seem to care
whether these people uh destroy their
own environment if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell